[Applause]
I'm going to be so cool I'm going to be
cool I know I
know wait wait till you see the movie
it's it's a little complicated but the
chemistry is amazing we're going to talk
about it but I'm I'm very excited that
you're here I'm going to be so cool I
might look at him more often just CU you
um frighten me in the most amazing ways
yes yes no I'm going to keep it
together it's you are nice yeah not like
that just like you know I'll just be I'm
fine no no well we met so same thing big
fan but we met before so I'm a little
I'm a little less nervous about it I'm a
lot nervous about this one okay when did
y'all meet did you meet before the film
uh it's it's a matter of conjecture we
don't know we don't agree on how we you
don't agree how do you think you met I I
believe we met in a um airport lounge no
no hard no parno where did you meet in
an elevator in a hotel oh my God it's so
different that's right so different
maybe it was an elevator in an airport
yeah these characters that we play in
the movie disagree about everything too
that's true like everything in the past
that they don't remember the same way
but that's what I find interesting yes
like vantage point and like point of
view like I find that very interesting
so you're stuck in an airport this whole
time yes we get we rerouted and uh we
get stuck in a one night we're snowed in
and we haven't seen each other in 20
years or something like that which is
awkward we have some unresolved things
yeah a few yeah a few yeah I was like I
I watch it I was like oh man this is so
layered um so wait if you if you were
trapped though with a co-star like that
you've worked with before who would you
you can't pick each other don't do that
yeah you have to pick someone else if
you were trapped in an airport who would
you pick that that I want to be or that
I that you want to not that you don't
want to be what kind of a movie is a
horror movie or this is a this is a no
this is a friend movie it's a friend
like what friend would you want to yeah
wait in real life who do we want to be
real just talking about
okay right I worked with her briefly she
was a blast I like that you went for a
blast and he went to horror yeah
explains a lot tells you something about
my work
experience maybe Pam Adlon be fun oh go
and I can always count on her to do most
of the talking okay well you might want
to be stuck with me then because I'm a
talker so will talk your head off um so
eight years off right from doing like
films and stuff like so why that I I
appreciate that cuz even in the music
world it's nice to have a break yeah
right I didn't try I just I basically
just been hanging around I mean yeah
like talking talking to my friends
raising my kids like redecorating I
that's the important thing too though
yeah and then during Co the script came
to me and I was like oh I've always
wanted to write I've always wanted to
write a screenplay so that's what
happened it's you know it's a movie
basically they're locked down in the
movie together and we were locked down
at the time yeah and I had all this time
to uh to write what a perfect movie to
do in the lockdown time it's really
y'all yeah yeah well I I think I think
you probably thought well you didn't
know how long the lockdown was going to
last so it was a movie that you could
have actually shot during the pandemic
that's what I mean yeah there's just two
of us that's it that's all except for
all the people that were actually in the
airport except for the yes the the
extras but we're the only ones who talk
they're not extras no these were it was
a working airport you know these were
actual people like they were real people
are you serious in fact I I recognize
some of
them um so I have to say you're both in
romcoms that are so massively popular
that people love and adore so I'm not
what you you are return to me is like
one of my favorite
what so wait what's your what's the best
time you feel to watch a romcom when do
you watch like it's like sad music when
do you listen to you know what I'm
saying when you're when you're getting
over being sick yes that's what people
tell me
anyway that is true yeah like when
you're recovering and you you feel like
you cracked it and you're on the on
upswing you need something nice yes kind
that's when I watch Doris Day the yeah
all those old
things about you that's what I do I
watch I well I watch a real well-known
film called return to
me and you've got me I watch all those
when you want to watch a romcom what do
you what mood are you in yeah what M I
don't I don't know I think here's my
honest answer when I find one when I'm
flipping flipping it's either Good
Fellas and people are going to kill each
other I'm I can go with that too I get
into The Equalizer whenever I'm like not
feeling and I just want to kick
someone's
ass it's a good movie um well it's not a
romcom but anyway their new movie what
happens later it's in theaters today so
I found this incredibly interesting
because I didn't find this out till
after I watched the movie but you
weren't initially going to be the lead
no no we tried to get someone else and
and uh she didn't want to be in it and
so then we landed on me and then we
landed on David okay right on yeah oh my
gosh first of all I want to hold back
conversation on that off camera but who
says no to M ran cool okay um but I'm
kind of glad I think it ends up how it's
supposed to end up because I honestly
after watching it I was like I can't
picture anyone else in that role it's
kind of the point of the movie actually
yeah you can't picture yeah yeah yeah I
love I'll say no more I'll say no more
she's like I don't want to spoil it yeah
we shot for 21 days we only had a teeny
amount of money 21 nights yeah maybe
that was the hard part the night part
that was shot in that minimal amount of
wow yeah yeah and there's just well like
we said before just two people in it so
I thought it was manageable when I got
this during the co I thought oh we
could we could do this we could figure
it out there's just to to you know it's
very distilled experience that and it
does play out like a play like I feel
like you could literally watch this on
stage on Broadway yeah initially was a
play but then it was sort of basically
Rewritten but yeah and we shot in
Arkansas we shot shot in Northwest
Arkansas and Bentonville which was was
fantastic really Fantastic's beautiful
we loved being there and we shot it in a
museum and the real airport so we
combined it cuz it needed to be a
magical in the movie yeah in the movie
you just think we're in the airport and
all of a sudden we're in a beautiful
airport and we're not so beautiful
airport well I love that you said
magical though cuz there is a lot of
magical realism like there's things that
happen that I was kind of like when I
was watching I was like wait what I was
like cuz things are talking directly at
you even in the trailer that's kind of
given away the environment is a but you
know I always think of it I love the
idea that there's a a larger plan
there's a benevolent Force out there and
it operates on these two idiots who
can't get it straight and there it's
forever sort of like trying to broker
their like making some peace or getting
some clarity or understanding the facts
getting some closure right yeah
absolutely so I noticed that you
dedicated Sora Efron so what's your
what's your favorite memory of
her I have a great question I um uh she
gave great dinner parties oh and and
they were all and actually actually I
started to understand that like the
being on the set with her was the idea
was it should feel like one of her
dinner parties like you wanted to talk
to everybody you didn't want it to end
there was great conversation and she had
like just pure delight in film making
and she you know I I understand now like
you have this quiet little Revelation at
like 5:30 in the morning about how
characters talk to each other and it's
just yours and then cut to you're on a
set and 150 people are trying to like
have opinions about that yeah trying to
make it alive you know and that's a
really delightful magical little TW turn
and and and she embraced that she loved
that I love that and dinner parties
those are exhausting to throw like I'm
always so tired I'm always like I'm
never going to do this again and then I
do it again but whatever should you
should tell her about uh getting the
dedication on on yeah we the you like
this the WG the WG the DGA the
Director's Guild is very proprietary
rightfully so like the very first thing
you see at the end of a movie is is the
the directed by credit and in order to
That's the Law it's the law in order to
usurp that you had we had to petition
the the DGA to like these are the
reasons why I'd like to dedicate it to
Nora and unanimously they voted yes oh
wow that's very cool was a beautiful
thing and it was nice after watching
this amazing story of these two people
and then seeing that that was really
cool it was a beautiful thing to do so
do people ask you just because you're in
romantic movies do they ask you for real
advice sometimes I think people get lost
in the fact that you're playing a
character and it's not really you but do
they stop you often and ask for advice
do they they don't stop me
oh maybe they should all right everybody
we are back with mag Ryan and David's
Acy in their new movie what happens
later Meg and David play a couple who
just couldn't work things out sometimes
things just don't work out and sometimes
there are definite deal breakers it's
time to find out out if we' tolerate
some relationship situations with a game
called I'm sorry but that's a deal
breaker I'm sorry but that's a deal
[Music]
breaker what would be amazing in life it
would be amazing in life if you really
were in this situation and somebody just
came in and saying that I'm sorry back
here and then you just leave so you save
your time anyway here's how it works I'm
going to hit the button and a relation
this button particularly and a
relationship situation will pop up on
the screen um then we'll each have to
say ifal for us and why yeah I'm totally
sure I'm a great host here's the first
one okay you're on a first date and he
takes a 10minute call from his
mom then then puts you on the
phone that's different for I feel like
people in the public eye have you ever
been on it with people and they're like
oh can you talk to me and I'm like is
this happening cuz you're in the public
like you know they're they get excited
cuz you're I think no matter what it's a
deal breaker
okay okay that's a deal
breaker it doesn't work Jesse where were
you doesn't
work what what about what about you is
it a dealbreaker what was the
question maybe you're the guy on the
phone may no is it is it would it be a
deal breaker if person know a good
friend of mine uh Bart frck wrote a
script in which he had a first date and
the guy stopped at a porta potty on the
way to the dinner and start and kept
talking to the girl while he was inside
the Porta poty she was outside and I
just thought it was one of the funniest
scenes I'd ever read I don't know if
that's a deal breaker hit
it I'm sorry but that's a deal
[Music]
Breer I think that would be a deal
breaker for me too that's weird I took
time to have dinner and you're going on
for 10 minutes okay yeah okay here we go
next
one okay okay he shout he shouts out
that's he shouts out that's what she
said when the minister at your sister's
wedding claims the ring doesn't fit it's
too
big oh my
God that's when you you made the right
choice that is not a deal breaker I'm
going to be honest with you I know I
think I'm attracted to a different type
of person that that I actually would be
like all right it's a throwback but I'll
take
it it's a it's a it's a throwback
classic but I don't think I would I'd be
like yeah I'm going home with that one I
think I'd have to make a joke would you
would that be a deal breaker what a joke
wedding or would you ever say that at a
wedding I wouldn't say say
that but it is an opportunity it is an
opportunity that you ad Miss I've got a
captive audience yeah I can't resist
trying to be funny sometimes I'm just
saying could happen it could happen it
could happen here we
go okay on the second date she invites
you up or he invites you up to her
apartment in which she has oh seven cats
12 rabbits and a rare Spix Mcall named
David
by the way I think you have shown up to
my mother's house like she has a lot of
animals so I was like I read that and I
was like do we do they visit my moms um
she has a lot of animals a maau named
David she'd be a fan i' be like Mrs
Clarkson all
right Miss interesting night um so what
about you would it would it be a deal
breaker I'm not a deal breaker you love
animals I love animals and the M I can
see I can see how it had a certain
appeal I love animals David is a funny
name for an animal though but think
about this so it comes back to the
apartment scenario like if you're in a
house and those are somewhere else I
think I'm fine with it but an apartment
I grew up in an apartment no oh it's an
apartment okay yeah that's an apartment
that's close that's close qu rabbit
that's close to 24 36 rabbit turns get
everywhere rabbits arex they roll we
keep ours outside Breer we keep ours
outside that's a deal breaker okay here
we
go okay he claims that under is the
proper way
to are y'all making fun of me this is
this is my crew making fun of me because
I like it to roll over the top okay he
claims that under is the proper way to
roll the toilet paper and it's a deal
breaker for him if you think otherwise
here's the thing it's not a deal breaker
for me I I prefer the toilet paper to
roll over the top but I also prefer to
have my own bathroom so I don't really
care what his bathroom looks like are
you over I don't like that he's setting
up a deal breaker right away yeah that's
a weird that's in a way a deal breaker
that's a character flaw yeah I'm
uncomfortable I'm a go do you are you a
person I'm an over are you a person that
likes it under or over I don't know that
about myself um you don't have a
preference no I'm OCD I'm thinking about
I'm over
[Applause]
okay I'm over I prefer over oh my God I
love love you so much okay here we go
one
more okay he reveals to you just before
your wedding that he was oh that he was
taken into an alien spaceship when he
was 23 and they'll be back for him in
about four
years is it you're waiting to him I
think well he's he's going to leave
maybe in four years which oh that sounds
good I know I I've never tried
long-distance relationships but seems
nice it's a long commute seems like
you'd get your you easy breasy four
years yeah yeah you're only committing
for four years sign me up
yeah cuz the other one sounds like
[Applause]
jail I don't know I don't know what I'd
say anyway do you know what you would
you just go for it I'd go for it the
four year part yeah I'm into it I would
feel uh I feel like I would love to be
in a therapy session with you just to
because every question you go big you go
the whole scope of it man you're a big
thinker I am very
literal yeah and a complimentary way no
I mean I mean it as a compliment I no I
mean like you like think of so much in
one question I'm like I'm just like I
don't know would you go to space or not
I'm so like you're Yale and I'm high
school
graduate that's the difference I would
love to be in therapy with you too
okay you probably would you wouldn't
have to
talk okay those are our deal breakers
what's the guy's name again that game
went oh David hey
okay oh he's here um okay everybody go
see what happens later it's incredible
and it's thought-provoking which is the
best kind of movie it will leave you
asking so many questions we'll be right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home